kuduro ce matin là au centre d'accueil
loisirs les loupiots de plaisir comme
chaque mercredi cette structure de la
commune accueille près une quarantaine
d'enfants âgés de 3 à 10 ans encadrés
par des animateurs de la ville à 20 3 4
4 au mieux faire après ce moment libre
dans la cour place aux activités du
matin
thibault a préparé quatre jeux de
réflexion et d'attention j'ai des
valeurs et le mont but ça va être des
données les vannes à ses valeurs aux
enfants par le biais d'activités par le
biais de petits jeux de de consignes de
règles c'est ce qui compte en fait c'est
d'être à l'écouté des enfants de pouvoir
toujours raide sur la surveillance mais
de faire des gens montent à de son côté
bénédicte est parti avec quelques jeunes
au gymnase léo lagrange un tournoi de
football inter centres d'accueil de
loisirs est organisée durant la matinée
depuis 2007 elle exerce le métier
d'animatrice à plaisir après un bep
sanitaire et social et son brevet
d'aptitude aux fonctions d'animateur
quand les enfants ils viennent nous voir
et nous disent oui c'était bien c'était
génial
on en veut encore
voilà c'est ça en fait qui fait plaisir
de voir les enfants contents et heureux
c'est la base du métier durant l'été la
commune ouvre quatre accueils de loisirs
les enfants sont accueillis de 7h30 à
18h 45 du lundi au vendredi les
animateurs travaillent entre 47 et 48
heures par semaine pour des indemnités
moyenne de 2000 euros la ville recherche
actuellement des collaborateurs pour
compléter ses équipes ont ce qu'on
attend c'est surtout du dynamisme du
peps une bonne logique
à défaut de beaucoup d'expérience on
leur demande d'avoir une certaine
logique
une organisation un peu de rigueur on a
au nom des étudiants qui sont en école
d'art qui vont pouvoir ouvrir un peu les
activités sur tout ce qui est artistique
c'est là que pour nous c'est vraiment un
plus
c'est c'est un bon apprentissage que
d'être déjà animateur parce que voilà ça
permet aux plus jeunes parfois de
trouver ce justement ce petit job d'été
et puis et puis il faut savoir que plus
tard sur un cv c'est une belle
expérience
prochaines sessions de recrutement
organisée à la maison de l'emploi de
plaisir mercredi 29 mai de 12h à 17h30